it's great to be joined today by nick
majuli who's the coo
at ritholtz wealth management and also
founder of
dollars and data a data focused personal
finance blog
i've been reading nick's articles for a
long time it's great to have you on nick
hey thanks david appreciate it so okay
to start with i want to talk about
um the biden tax plan a little bit
and what the implications would be how
likely it is to happen but before we
even get into that
as a general principle when we look at
the stock market based on presidential
terms
my personal analysis is that the stock
market tends to return a higher uh
tends to see a higher return under
democratic presidents than republican
presidents
it's not an overwhelming difference so
the first question is
is that distinction relevant to
presidential policy
i do not think it is i think most of
that stuff when you really look at the
data
there's a lot of noise in there and
there was like obviously you're right
that you know democratic presidents tend
to have a slightly higher return
um but it's also kind of biased by
certain things you know you think about
uh
hoover and he was like in great
depression so that kind of messes things
up you think about it you know which
time period you want to use clinton
probably have the best returns ever i
know it's the 90s so like there's all
these outliers that kind of move things
around a little bit
um and of course presents do affect
policy which affects markets
i don't think it's it's linked as we
think i think it's probably a lot more
noise unfortunately
would it be fair to say then that
the argument you sometimes hear from the
right that the stock market is a
disaster during democratic presidents
that certainly isn't true yeah i don't
think that's true i think that the same
is also true on the other side i think
it's a disaster during democratic i
think that's all just
you know political talk coming out one
of the interesting things that you write
in your recent article about the biden
tax plan
is that there certainly is an impact on
one's
personal finances and net worth from
presidents but that it often has much
more to do with tax policy than it does
with the ups and downs of the stock
market and that's a really important
thing to understand
so when you start looking at what the
economy
might be like from a personal finance
standpoint are you focusing actually
more on tax policy than expected stock
stock market movement
yeah i mean for what like for for you
and i and for most people like
what how tax policy changes is going to
affect the dollars coming into your
accounts and
how much dollars you have to pay out to
the government and that's going to have
a much bigger impact than
you know how the market might
necessarily react and of course you know
it's one of these things you can't
really know but i know tax policy
for sure changes people's decisions and
behavior in a much bigger way than
i think just minor moves in the stock
market will
so let's talk a little bit about the
biden tax plan what when we
did a dive into it a few weeks ago some
of the notable things
were the change to the corporate uh
income tax rate
going from 21 to 28 percent repealing
the trump tax cuts and you would see
long-term cap gains rates go from about
24
to close to 40 percent you'd see that
top marginal tax rate go
up i think it's about three points to
the pre-trump era and then
and then very importantly right now
social security taxes stop at about
130 dollars in income roughly i don't i
know that's not exactly right
the biden proposal would then reinstate
that twelve point four percent tax
from four hundred thousand dollars and
up completely uncapped which if done
is a massive amount of revenue for for
the government
to start with is it accurate that those
under 400 000 a year in income will not
see an
increase which has been a big topic of
political debate
they should not see an increase in
income tax
now there are if everything in the plan
went through there are certain ways in
which
for example if you're getting property
if you're inheriting property you may
have to pay taxes on that if there's
unrealized gains that you wouldn't have
had to pay
in the you know in the in the current
state of the world so
no income tax is going to be increased
on those people but you might see
um other types of taxes show up given
other life events as i said if you're
inheriting property specifically that's
one that's going to be very
relevant and with that property
inheritance scenario is that
based on the size of the estate or it
could be regardless of the size of the
estate
uh so so there's a little bit of both so
the estate tax
right now allows for 11 point million
11.6 million per single person or 23.2
for a couple you can pass on you know no
estate tax
um and then there's also something
called stepped up basis what that means
is let's say you know
your grandparents had a you know a stock
and they bought apple in like you know
1995 or whatever
and now it's got you know a million
dollars in gains they can when they die
they can pass that on to their heirs
no taxes owed on the gain but if they
get rid of that rule
anyone regardless of who you are you get
that you're going to have to pay the tax
on the difference there and that's also
true of real estate among other things
now
i don't think that's actually going to
pass there's a lot i've talked a lot of
tax professionals about this
like yeah there's no way stepped up base
is going to be completely
gotten rid of because it's a very
complex thing i think the reason they
use it to get rid of stepped up bases is
because
it's just simpler not to have to track
how you improved a real estate property
for over 40 years and
every single home repair and then trying
to track the basis of that as a
nightmare for
for the irs and for individuals so
that's why they just kind of wipe it
clean it's just a little bit easier that
way
so i i want to talk about the likelihood
of any of these different things passing
now to even start that conversation if
democrats don't take
control of the senate with a 50-50 tie
by getting the two georgia runoffs
having kamala harris as the tie-breaking
vote
does any of this stuff pass or is this
all i mean is tax reform even getting
done without a democratic senate
yeah so i don't think it's gonna get i
mean even if they pass it so remember
here's here's the thing even if they do
get you know
they win the two georgia senate races um
kamal harris you know
uh cast a tie breaking vote you still
have to like argue for all these things
this is like the wish list all these
different things are the wish list but
what's going to happen is they're going
to go back and forth with republicans
and even there's going to be some
democrats that say i don't want to
eliminate this or i don't want to do
this so
this is really like the best case
scenario just to start and they're going
to bargain and some of these things are
going to come and go and i think
for example stepped up basis will
probably be one of the things if i had
to guess that gets kicked out
um first so so for now still continuing
in the scenario where democrats do have
the senate but there's negotiation
i have a really hard time imagining that
social security
will be uncapped from 400 000 and up
and and the reason i say that without
making any moral judgment about it is
that is millions and tens of millions of
dollars in taxes
for for a lot of people and of course
part of it can be avoided by not earning
income through wages and we know about
the way that that can be done
i don't know how that gets passed even
the democratic senate
yeah that's a good point i think yeah
you're right in terms of time people
will just
okay immediately companies like okay
your new salary cap is
400 000 and we're going to pay you all
this extra equity income or this extra
thing
they're going to find ways to get money
to you in ways that are not
classified as labor income now i think
some people are probably still just
gonna take the hit and like okay you
know
the employers take six percent i have to
pay six percent whatever but yeah a lot
of people are gonna
shift salaries around and they're gonna
be like oh there's gonna be the 400k
club out there
so i promise that so what's the most
reliable way i have sometimes financial
advisors who will write to me or they'll
call into my show
and they'll say you know we already know
that just increase increasing income tax
rates is not a great way to capture
necessarily more revenue because a lot
of really wealthy people
are not earning through wages so then
you've got to maybe look at capital
gains but then there's also different
ways
to avoid paying capital gains taxes or
you can always just kind of wait it out
because with capital gains a lot of it
has to do with when are you realizing
the gain and if you don't like what you
would pay now you can wait for a
different administration
in your experience like if the
government was determined we want to
capture more
of the different types of income that
people are making what would be the most
sort of iron-clad way to do it i don't
that's a great question i think this is
the
question that's like everyone's trying
to figure out how do you curb inequality
really that's really the question how do
you curb inequality and someone's like
okay we can just raise capital gains
like
well let's say let's say you know the
probability of the this whole thing
happening where
you know democrats take over the senate
we let's say it's like a 95
chance right now predict it's putting it
like 24 25 percent so it's a one in four
chance right now
let's say it was 95 percent what you're
gonna see is people are gonna start
realizing the gains now they're gonna
start going through
there was even this thing where in 2010
i think the estate tax was like zero and
a surprisingly large number of people
happen to die that year so it's like
people will literally change their lives
and somehow just accept the grave to
avoid taxes so
i don't know what's the best way to do
that i wish i had a better answer for
you like
you can do things like that people have
tried wealth taxes but that's like on
the really really you know
rich people but that's tough like how do
you determine wealth how do you you know
capture that how prevent people from
fleeing there's all sorts of ways to get
at this
i think it's really difficult i mean
capital gains is a start but
it depends how big the jump is i mean
23.8 to 39.6
is a big jump and that's going to change
people's behavior if that were to happen
so then going to the next scenario which
is democrats don't get the senate
is there any tax reform getting done in
the next two years if democrats don't
get the senate
i don't think so i think we're going to
be in gridlock i mean i'm obviously not
an expert at that thing
but i i don't see how it's going to
happen how you know republicans if they
can prevent it from happening
they're happy with what's going on right
now so i think we'll just have more of
the same
so for the average person who makes an
average salary
maybe has access to some kind of
matching contribution
if they're an education maybe it's a 403
b or a 401k uh
you know with with our staff we do a
simple ira
average person average normal person
does it make
any sense to be making any changes to
what you are doing on the basis of who
is in the white house
uh i would say no definitely not i mean
as going back to kind of our earlier
discussion like you know markets rise
markets fall under any sort of present
you can look through history like they
have drawdowns 20 30
drawdowns almost every single president
and markets go up during almost every
present i mean there's obviously
exceptions
you know but i don't think it's the
president's fault that you know oh we
have hyperinflation or we have this or
that like
i don't think it's necessarily always
the president's fault for that type of
thing you know even when fdr took over
in the great depression like
initially like there was a lot of hope
but still the economy was sluggish for a
while and finally got back together so
when the uh coronavirus uh when the
initial coronavirus dip happened in sort
of like mid-march
the internet was riddled with hot takes
about sell now or buy more
options or wait buy back in in a month
this sort of stuff now my view having
read everything from ben
graham a hundred years ago and
understanding
what warren buffett's perspective is and
the great jack
bogle and so on and so forth my view has
always been
i don't think i can time the market i
don't think i'm slick enough i've got a
full-time job
and understanding that each year
a huge portion of the gain comes from
a very small number of trading days and
if you're timing
you could miss one of those days and
miss out on a lot of the return for a
particular year not to mention there are
tax implications to buying and selling
etc
are there exceptions to that where it
makes sense to either try to time the
market based on the news cycle
or legislatively or or in any other way
i would generally say no i would never
try to do something like that there are
certain quantitative models that use
sort of a trend following to look at
like 200-day moving averages and that
but i don't want to get into all the
technicality of that there are
some that do and even those like a lot
of those models which traditionally have
worked for the last 20 years
failed during covet because it was such
a quick decline and it came back so
quickly
that quick v recovery that the models
had never seen anything like that and so
they weren't they didn't have any data
to prepare for that to jump back in so
you see a lot of people that are
actually
the best in the business at trend
following you know got a little bit
burned this year unfortunately
um but that's kind of that's what
happens you know it's just that's that's
the nature of markets
so briefly just talking about corporate
tax now as we've been talking all about
kind of kind of personal financial um
there's this idea again in the biden tax
plan of raising the corporate income tax
rate from 21 to 28 percent now a lot of
small business owners including me
uh set up as an s corporation all of our
income is passed through in other words
the the business itself is paying some
stat to quote donald trump some
statutory amount which i think in
massachusetts is like 450
or something like that and then
basically i'm getting a k1
as an owner and i'm paying tax on my
personal income taxes so
the corporate tax rate i don't believe
actually affects me so it's kind of a
two-part question
are small businesses affected by the
corporate tax rate who really is
affected by that
yeah so that's that it depends i mean
you're right
there's a lot a lot of income especially
amongst you know higher income families
is
coming through partnerships and smaller
businesses not necessarily like
you know corporate tax is going to be
for i think much larger businesses
so it will affect certain people but i
think as you said a lot of people have
smaller businesses they use
pass-throughs a lot of law firms or
pass-throughs or partnerships things
like that so it's going to affect some
people
um and it'll probably affect the stock
market in some way if that were to come
to pass because obviously corporate tax
means you know less profits so just
simple as that so
um but yeah once again this is how
likely is this
as of right now it doesn't seem too
likely one of the things that's never
made sense to me and i've asked a lot of
economists about this you hear this
talking point
from businesses if you raise the
corporate tax rate it will be bad for
the economy
and it will be bad in general because
businesses won't invest in growing their
business
to me it seems completely
counterintuitive because if i'm a
business owner
and i can take profits at a 20 tax rate
or take profits at a 30 tax rate
avoiding a 30
tax seems like something i would be more
inclined to do and the way you avoid tax
of course is by making capital
investments so
if you apply a demand side approach
wouldn't a higher corporate tax rate
encourage investment in a business
because you're incentivized to avoid
what is a higher rate of tax
yeah i mean you that's one way to look
at it um you can also say like okay well
if my taxes some you know who doesn't
want like do you want
you get it you want 70 cents do you want
80 cents like oh i'll take 70 since
you're gonna give it to me right so like
you're still making money either way um
i do think the logic for that argument
is correct but it has to be at a much
higher rate i think going 21 to 28
it's like where are you on the curve
that's always the question this is the
big debate like if we went from
obviously 21 to 100 you can see
obviously that that would completely
devastate business
there but where is that how big is it
measuring that that's really the crux of
the argument and people will argue on
both sides and i think
you know if it was clear we would just
know it we wouldn't be debating it
that's the problem a lot of these
debates the reason our debates is
because
it's not clear-cut in the data and if it
was clear-cut we just wouldn't debate it
anymore i think that's kind of how this
works yeah and there's a lot of i think
there's a lot of bad faith actors on
both sides with these issues that want
to
create edge cases that nobody's arguing
for like for example
people against the 15 minimum wage will
often say
well if 15 is better because people have
more money what about 150 and of course
nobody's talking about 150 150 wouldn't
be an equilibrium wage 150 would not be
a wage that's in line with cost of
living and i i'm wondering if you also
think that to really discuss this stuff
we have to eliminate these kind of straw
man edge cases and think about the the
meat of the curve as you're talking
about not the extremes
yeah i don't think you can use
exceptions to make to try and make rules
or argue rules it's really tough there
are
obviously for example one of the biggest
things in the investment literature is
this whole idea
of the black swan it's like oh you look
at this average distribution and the
exception
is the most important thing because the
exception changes everything so
i kind of agree with some of that logic
sometimes but sometimes it's also a
straw man
when are you talking about are you
talking about in a risk context are you
talking about in a minimum wage context
obviously yeah like why not 150
because that makes obviously no sense
like there's too many jobs where the
equilibrium wage is just
far too low compared to you know 115
hour
so i completely see both sides of it um
but yeah i agree that you should try to
like
where's the meat of the distribution i
think it's a good way of looking at it
we've been speaking
with nick majuli who is coo at ritholtz
wealth management also founder of
of dollars and data i might have missed
one of the of your founder of
of dollars and data yes uh personal
finance blog that i subscribe to nick
really appreciate your time and
and having you on yes thank you
appreciate it david